[Music]
what's up everybody
Helen here it's a pretty good time to be
an adult cartoon from the swear happy
South Park to the constant flashbacking
a family guy and those guys back at the
factory can suck it I'm gonna get out of
this place one day to the liquor fueled
antics of Archer & Co many animated
shows for grown ass folks have become
enduring 21st century classics but we'd
argue that possibly the most adult
cartoon of them all is one Bojack
horseman it's not as profane a South
Park nor as sexually charged as Archer
because I can take from you crazy but in
terms of catapulting its audience into a
befuddled cloud of angsty depression the
simultaneously hilarious and
gut-wrenching world of Hollywood never
fails to deliver look I gotta go I feel
like you didn't really finish the pep
talk I know but I got a movie to put
together best of luck part of what makes
Bojack so beloved is the way it defies
convention and not just in regards to
the ethics of interspecies romantic love
the show features frequently depressed
and effed up characters frequently doing
pretty depressing and effed up things
particularly in its later seasons the
show is less about the lovable antics of
your favorite on-screen pals than it is
an emotionally trying look into the
lives of severely flawed and unhappy
people
the most recent half season seems to
depict an evolving version of Bojack
fighting his addictions and becoming a
better horse along with some smaller
also promising character arcs for his
friends but now that the show is coming
to a conclusion it has to wrestle with
its fundamental underpinning despite
their many attempts the characters don't
really change understanding why the
characters on Bojack are so static
requires examining the greater
conversation the show is having with the
familiar form of entertainment the
comedic sitcom will explain in this
wisecrack edition on change in Bojack
horseman oh and spoilers ahead for the
show thus far now let's dive into a
recap of season 6 so far which finds
Bojack enduring and even semi thriving
in rehab where he waters plants
accidentally gets his sober horse doctor
drunk and speaks unnecessary truths to
the not powerful recovering addicts
around him really everyone's being
honest
Doug over here who keeps dressing in a
suit and tie even though he's never
getting his finance job back eventually
forced to return to real life
Bojack finds himself haunted by memories
of the morally bankrupt horse he used to
be he embarks on a cross-country trip to
make amends and figure out what to do
with himself finally settling it seems
on teaching acting at the hipster
studded liberal arts college Wesleyan
where his half-sister hollyhock is
studying
however just when it seems like Bojack
is really becoming a better version of
that vodka-soaked self-obsessed
celebrity we've come to know and yell
out in our heads something else happens
specifically the eponymous character
doesn't appear at all in the final
episode of this half season instead the
show focuses entirely on the victims of
his toxic behavior from Sarah Lynn who
is super dead under mysterious
circumstances currently being
investigated by two hard-nosed reporters
- Gina who still has PTSD from the time
budget cut - into character and
straight-up choked her - Kelsey whose
career is still suffering thanks to
bojack's antics if you told me when we
were starting out the one day you'd be
doing chicken commercials not a
commercial worst of all this half of the
season ends with hollyhock just on the
precipice of discovering a horrible
truth who is he that when Bojack was in
new mexico
he took his exes daughter penny to prom
got her friends wasted and almost hooked
up with her wolf so what is the series
setting up for in the final eight
episodes and what issues should you
expect the show to grapple with we have
an idea but first we have to talk about
the Big Bang Theory it's relevant we
swear
now when Greek philosopher Heraclitus of
ephesus said change is the only constant
in life he clearly couldn't have
predicted the television sitcom the
sitcom or a typically family-friendly
comedic television show is fundamentally
rooted in its characters and those
characters are generally rooted in
predictability as scholar Jason Mattel
argues in his book Complex TV while it
may seem that a pleasure of serial
narratives is watching characters grow
and develop over time most television
characters are more stable and
consistent rather than changeable
entities he notes that even in the face
of life altering events characters are
more likely to accumulate experiences
rather than to actually learn and change
from them the way your life coach
suggests you should we see this all
throughout the history of sitcoms from
the self-absorbed major Frank Burns on
the 70 show mash to the goofy antics of
Kramer to the even goofier antics of
Michael Scott
Michael did you fall into a koi pond ah
can't really hear you I think we're sort
of a bad connection as much as we love
The Sopranos and Mad Men for their
psychological complexity and deep
ever-evolving characters we love plenty
of shows precisely for their lack of
these qualities it's because friends is
not The Sopranos that we want to watch
it at 2:00 p.m. when we're hung over or
2:00 a.m. well we can't sleep my life is
an embarrassment I should just go live
under somebody's stairs minor changes
might occur episode 2 episode as the
overarching plots are driven forward the
show's themselves remain fundamentally
static marriages promotions and other
developments are only skin-deep the
relationships between the central cast
don't really change nor do the
characters themselves this structure
makes them easy to consume you can dip
in at any point and know exactly what to
expect but more importantly it blesses
them with a promise that whatever
happens everything will have gone back
to normal by the end of the episode
comfortable familiar always the same
usually set in cozy houses cafes or bars
these shows keep us nestled in a comfy
status quo that makes the bitter
difficulties of life feel far away for
at least 20 minutes or so imagine if
Homer Simpson suddenly didn't want to
buy to that jelly filled donut you would
probably understandably spiral what
makes Bojack horseman so heartbreaking
to watch is that while the show
maintains the sitcom format by keeping
its characters on a perpetual emotional
hamster wheel those characters actually
seem to want to change and their
inability to do so is the crux of the
show's painful resonance the perfect
foil for the Showboat jack horseman is a
delightful meta show horsing around a
series best described by bow Jack
himself look for a lot of people life is
just one long hard kick in the urethra
and sometimes when you get home from a
long day of getting kicked in the
urethra you just want to watch a show
about good likeable people who love each
other
where you know no matter what happens at
the end of 30 minutes everything it's
gonna turn out okay Kate - the turning
out okay part is that like most sitcoms
nothing really changes the characters
are monolithic simply drawn and reliably
themselves in this 90s comedy evocative
of The Cosby Show
Bojack played the bubbly gold hearted
father figure - three adorable orphans
reciting a cheesy platitude at the end
of each episode
we're a family now no matter what and I
will always be there for you the show's
sugary tone broad humor and familiar
rhythms made Bojack rich and famous but
even 30 years later he's still haunted
by the question of whether it was any
good still
throughout the series Bojack has sought
solace and comfort and horsing around
reruns which he consumes with an
enthusiasm he typically reserves only
for horse tranquilizers reciting lines
reminiscing over bad jokes and generally
reflecting on what seems to be the best
era of his life he appears to long for
the simple easy emotional connections
experienced by the force he sees on TV
even attempting to assume a good-natured
fatherly role with saralyn when she
briefly moves in with him in season 1 to
disastrous metaphorically incestuous
results we can pretty much all relate to
Bojack sentiment life would be easier if
we lived on a static happy family TV
show where everything is relatively
predictable but for him since he
literally was on one the contrast
becomes all the more heartbreaking
horsing around is often explicitly
contrasted with bojack's real-life and
that's where things get really
interesting having lived the most
significant years of his existence on a
sitcom set
Bojack has come to understand the utter
happiness of this inert sitcom world the
most important thing is you gotta give
the people what they want even if it
kills you even if it empty you out until
there's nothing left to empty as much as
he longs to return endlessly to the
place in which nothing ever changes he
is tormented by the fact that this is
ironically and tragically exactly what
his life has become he's become a piece
of who never changes or perhaps more
precisely
Bojack is living in an existential 'i
dreadful shadow of a sitcom we can make
out as much from the opening credits of
the show which until season 6 depict
Bojack rising from his bed in a half
drug case as he floats a series of
background images slowly flash behind
him the backgrounds change from season
to season
but the spaced out unreal quality
remains hinting that he might continue
on this carousel until the very end
that's what the characters in Bojack
horseman do they go round and round in
the same interior tracks always ending
back where they started much like the
characters on full house or the Brady
Bunch
they
to be faded never to really change
despite trying really really hard to the
prime example is Bojack who in a nature
befitting a suffering addict professors
to want to transform himself in his life
but never quite succeeds in the second
season Bojack makes a conscious attempt
to overhaul his personality by plugging
into a series of chipper metaphor mixing
self-help tapes they don't work because
their attempts at instantaneous change
only really serve to tinker about on the
surface of a person a smile painted
sloppily on the outermost layer of the
self he takes up running as part of his
self-improvement quest but rarely gets
far at the end of that season's final
episode he takes to the hill outside his
home once again he grunts complains and
collapses almost immediately
only to be roused by a voice above him
it's the macaque who has been quietly
jogging through each episode every day
it gets a little easier yeah but you got
to do it every day that's the hard part
but it does get easy here the primate
seems to voice the show's perspective on
change that it's hard and life will kick
your asses you tried to shift your
ingrained behaviors but then even the
smallest change can be super rewarding
lesson learned right not so fast season
3 returns only to watch Bojack behave
selfishly ie sleeping with Todd's ex
Emily succumbed to his addictions ie
going on a pre AAA bender with saralyn
and feel depressed and isolated Lisa V
this incredible dialogue free underwater
episode his inability to change is
perhaps satirized in the episode stop
the presses in which Bojack has to leap
through hoops in an attempt to cancel a
newspaper subscription as if driving
home the point that in this universe
even the most my new bureaucratic
alteration is impossible with the
capital I am but arguably the biggest
joke in quotation marks comes at the end
of the season
Bojack attempts to commit suicide by
forcing his car to crash only to change
his mind last minute and is promptly
rewarded with the majestic sight of a
pack of horses running wild and free
that's right he's exactly where he was
the end of season 2 wishing he could run
this continues for the next couple of
seasons as Bojack indulges in his vices
and hurts the people he loves
eventually contributing to saralyn's
death in the planetarium after going on
a days long epic bender with her right
saralyn saralyn after her funeral Bojack
reflects on his toxicity and in one
rather on-the-nose moment seems to state
the show's apparent thesis i don't know
how to be Diane doesn't get better and
it doesn't get easier I can't keep lying
to myself saying I'm gonna change I'm
poison so much for self-improvement even
when you think Bojack could be getting
slightly better say thanks to the
influence of his half-sister hollyhock
he'll be back with the fifth season
centered around his new TV show filbert
and which he'll completely devolve into
an opiate fuelled terror the other
characters don't fare much better at
least in terms of personal development
Princess Carolyne struggles with her
addiction to work difficulty maintaining
a relationship and then over her desire
for a child and then her ambivalence
about having a child regardless of the
scenario she both feels overwhelmed and
doesn't feel like she's doing enough she
goes from agent to manager from
girlfriend to single mom from ruthless
to empathetic but never really changes
meanwhile Diane agonizes over her
integrity whether it's the societal
impact of her girl crush videos or her
role in enabling bojack's bad behavior
the sense that her work and her life
should mean more always haunts her she
seeks to express herself creatively with
integrity in a refugee camp or in
Vietnam or in writing a memoir and yet
each season the characters wind up
pretty much back where they began Todd
is still a man-child
mr. peanut butter still lives in mostly
blissful ignorance and Bojack even 30
years later is still the derelict horse
from horsing around
unlike your cheers or I love Lucy's
though there is no comfort in this
static state there is no peace in
bojack's tragic flaws because Bojack
horseman shines a light on the dark
crevices of humanity or horse manatee
that sitcoms ignore its characters are
simultaneously deeper and more tragic
than your typical Frasier fare the
repetitive nature of each character's
story feels less like the fun-loving
antics of all in the family and more
like the actual living nightmare of a
human being trying to change in real
life
the unchanging nature of things in
Hollywood becomes a torturous
existential trap a bitter and continual
reminder of the fact that real life is
kind of the same no matter what happens
today don't wake up the same person
tomorrow no promotion no marriage no big
symbolic change will take you away from
who you are
so bojack's effectively stuck right not
quite the show isn't content to simply
teach us that people can't change no
matter how hard they try season six thus
far feels more devastating than that
rather than dark sitcom like repetition
the eight episodes witness Bojack
actually seeming to evolve in a
meaningful way now be it slowly and
painfully still imperfect he enables
teenage Rehab president Jamison to
behave badly and act out much as he did
with Sarah Lynn but even when he messes
up
he's trying yes he keeps vodka around
because he thinks he's special ink will
withstand his addiction and yes that
vodka accidentally gets dr. horse drunk
but he stays with said horse doctor and
repeatedly attempts to get him back on
the wagon you know progress plus he
urges Diane to get on meds tries to find
Todd an asexual partner and even brings
Princess Carolyn's baby a present though
it naturally is a portrait of himself as
narcissus Halle even gives mr. peanut
butter a crossover episode and by the
end of the eighth episode other
characters seem to making small changes
to Diane goes on antidepressants
princess Carolyn seems to reset her
priorities Todd realizes his perpetual
childlike nature makes him an excellent
Manny and mr. peanut butter attempts to
atone for his infidelity these changes
are small maybe even microscopic but
they're there every inch of change has
been hard-won it's something meaningful
happening maybe
and it feels most profound in episode 7
when beau Jack travels the country
visiting some of the people he's hurt
and/or alienated he apologizes tries to
make things right and genuinely seems to
atone for who he is he appears to ditch
some of the superficial trappings of his
persona allowing his hair to gray as he
reconciles with his former hairdresser
who he got fired from horsing around he
even tries to get over his lifelong
aversion to other horses and then
episode 8 episode 8 is so depressing
because it reminds us of the Bojack we
used to know before the extensive horse
therapy and the apology
before the even vague sense of decency
or desire to be a role model for
hollyhock we're forced to remember every
mistake he made and the long list of
victims left in the wake of his
pathological selfishness and we're left
wondering will the changes Bojack is
made even madder
is there a plan your life when you've
heard enough people that your own
personal evolution becomes irrelevant
bojack's journey has been one of the
most emotional of any animated TV
protagonists and yet it's paved entirely
with the hurt and damaged souls of the
people mostly women he's injured along
the way well the show may be indicating
that Bojack has finally changed it also
suggests that he may have caused more
damage than even the most thorough
evolution could excuse so what does it
all mean
well we think that the writers of Bojack
horseman have always situated horsing
around as the imperfect mirror image to
the actual show they're creating horsin
around maybe comforting in this
platitudes but it's also disingenuous
nobody gets horribly hurt and nobody is
particularly deeper honest on Bojack
it's the opposite everybody is hurting
often horribly and the characters are
deep and often quite honest about their
pain I mean yeah I got secretly drugged
for months on end to the point where I
was living a nightmare in which I
couldn't recognize my own body or
understand what was happening to my
brain but other than that it was a
pretty chill experience I should have
protected you I really wanted to be a
good dad to you hollyhock well turns out
you're not my dad at all yeah good thing
I guess the stasis that makes shows like
coursing around comforting makes Bojack
brilliant and sometimes borderline
intolerable to watch and we have
literally no idea what's gonna happen
next sorry but what do you guys think is
Bojack beyond redemption is changing
oneself essentially impossible and if so
should any of us really bother to be
better let us know what you think in the
comments
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]